okay let's uh bring in Muhammad Jam Jun
he's live for us in West Jerusalem and
Muhammad I understand you have some more
details relating to the compound behind
you that may well play a role in this
exchange that's right NE let me tell you
where we are we're in front of a
compound that houses the main Police
Headquarters here in West Jerusalem now
inside that compound are relatives of
six Palestinian women who have been
released from prison
they are among those 39 Palestinians
that are currently in offer prison where
you just heard Charles Stratford he's in
front of that prison in the occupied
West Bank we're told they are going to
be transferred here later this evening
we're not sure exactly what time now
inside there are the relatives we've
spoken to some of them they are trying
to find out what the next steps will be
when it comes to their relatives who are
going to be released as I said these are
six women among the convictions that
they have uh that they have had among
them are incitement on social media as
well as attempted stabbings and
attempted ramming attacks they also have
their legal representation there now
what we've heard from the families of
these Six Women is that they are
extremely concerned at this hour about
what is going to happen they don't want
to talk publicly to the media yet
they're not sure that they can and the
reason they are so worried is because of
the fact that these women are from
occupied East Jerusalem and that means
that they fall under the jurisdiction of
the national security minister that is
the far right-wing national security
minister itar Bing gavier just yesterday
he had said that he will not allow any
Celebrations by Palestinians in any area
where his police force has jurisdiction
so occupied East Jerusalem would fall
under that and that is one of the
reasons why these people are so
concerned now we've heard this type of
rhetoric from itar bin in the past there
have been times in the past when
Palestinian prisoners have been released
back to occupy these Jerusalem and they
were not not allowed to celebrate but we
are trying to find out more details we
would like to speak to some of the women
who will be released formally later this
evening but as of now much concern a lot
of worry from these relatives because
they just don't know what's going to
happen they're obviously a bit relieved
that they will be seeing their family
members in the coming hours but they
just don't know what's going to happen
next what they'll be allowed to mhed
muhamed I'm afraid I'm I'm going to have
to jump in because we want to show our
viewers these pictures of Palestinian
detainees being being released that's
the scene at the offer uh facility
that's in uh close to ralo in the
occupied West Bank we're talking about
39 women and youngsters
teenagers to be released as a part of
this ongoing exchange this happening a
short while after we got confirmation
that the Israeli captives held in Gaza
were now all on Israeli soil having
crossed through the Rafa Crossing and
then on into Israel so Muhammad back to
you an indication that this is all
moving forward as it's expected to and
as you've already suggested some of
those individuals may be heading in your
direction
let's mam yeah go
ahead just saying that yes we are
expecting them to be arriving within the
next hour or two that's what we've heard
from the relative they don't know the
precise time obviously they are relieved
that they will be seeing their relatives
later this evening but again as I
mentioned before they are very concerned
about what the next steps are they just
don't know what exactly the conditions
will be for the release yet that's why
their legal representation is also with
those family members inside this
compound behind us which houses the
police headquarters in West Jerusalem
now obviously you see a security
presence here it seems to be more
stepped up in the last few minutes and
we expect that as those detainees who
have now been released start getting
closer we will probably see more
security because they want to keep this
area cordoned off all right Muhammad uh
unfortunately we have to correct what
we've just seen uh obviously this is a
fast moving situation lots of images
coming in from different places as this
exchange grinds forward what we're
actually looking at are scenes of
Israeli captives coming what we believe
is is into Israeli territory these
pictures are recent of course it is the
international Committee of the Red Cross
red cresant that are coordinating that
exchange 13 Israeli Nationals some of
them potentially duel Nationals we're
yet to have that clarified 10 ties one
Filipino involved in that exchange as
well but not part of the main body of
that deal